that this is something you have got to  this is something I've watched like five  times ready a stowaway cat emerged  mid-flight after a pilot took off and  French Guiana the cat clinging to the  planes left wing there you see it on the  right of your screen ultimately crawled  forward and stayed on the plane's wing  until landing the pilot says he isn't  sure how the cat got aboard but noted  that it seemed to enjoy the ride you  know sue Bale can talk about all the  things that Mixpanel does for its people  for its customers for the world but this  is what the internet was made for this  is why we have the World Wide Web and  last night it truly served its purpose  for me I loved it